you know something else I want to talk
about here just mention briefly folks is
you're probably all aware we live in
security-conscious times here in America
and I just want to take a second and
applaud the security force here at NBC
they do an amazing job you probably met
some of them when you were coming in
really great crack security cream here
crack security team and I passed these
people every day I see the security guys
men and the women that are protecting us
here in the building and I see them and
they're doing such a good job and I
started to think the other day wouldn't
it be interesting if I could see what it
takes to be a top-flight security guard
here at 30 Rockefeller Center you know I
wanted to know if I had the right stuff
if I could do it so folks guess what I
did I joined up for a night that's right
I gave up my cushy late-night job and I
joined in on the security force here at
Rockefeller Center I brought a camera
crew with me and this is what happened
take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
you're at the main station for NBC
security and I'm here with Oliver Gordon
one of our top security people how are
you sir I'm fine let me ask you tonight
for one night only I'm joining the force
is it known as the force no security can
we say that I'm part of an elite squad
well that's a little special ring and
with inner ring oh that's nice that's
good that's good that's okay it's okay
one of the greatest things about
security guards is they get to carry
around that ring of keys that sort of
open anything do you have one of those
oh yeah we've got our keys what do you
got let me see that hold that up jingle
that about ten on here that's all yeah
check this out
but this opens every door in New York
City and Staten Island I also use this
at Christmastime
[Music]
they officer down
so yeah how would you say my first day
is going so far this is where if there's
gonna be trouble it's gonna start here
and it's gonna end here is that right
that's right someone shows their ID and
then it shows up on this monitor do you
check the face it shows up here with the
face of the guy coming through that's
right if that face doesn't match up what
do you do stop do you stop them how do
you stop them stop no elbow to the
throat soften the throat right here
drive the tip of the elbow until you
feel the back of the throat that means
you've crushed their windpipe you got it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
hello how are you everything all right
[Music]
[Applause]
which she ran away yeah
doesn't seem suspicious to you have you
seen her before did you've been here
about five years now not a long time
when you think about it
not long at all sometimes people put in
five years just to make everybody
comfortable
[Music]
this is the nerve center for NBC
security right here can you tell me who
is this guy right here that's uh officer
Brown officer Brown officer Brown do you
hear me
this is Conan O'Brien speaking to you
from Late Night with Conan O'Brien
starring me Conan O'Brien
how are you could you give me a wave
right now so I can confirm it's you give
me a favor just Pat this guy in the head
is walking through right now give a
little pat on the head
[Applause]
all right I'm proceeding to other levels
if there's any problems at all
my code word tonight is I'm known as the
red fox or night fox
I prefer night fox to be honest hello
hold this that really hurt
I accomplished nothing can you unlock
this woman's we don't have the key yes
you do I got the key look it's really
worn like you've used it a lot this is
like Conan merchandise but when's the
last time you saw some Dateline
merchandise I don't think anything
remember Eddie you know I'm saying it's
weird your hand is moist
just to make sure that that's that okay
[Applause]
no Forks sir you know that this is the
dateline offices right here there's a
Stone Phillips right there have you met
Stone yes I have I work with him nice
guy right kind of robotic have you
actually seen him take nourishment no
really there's this theory that he's
powered by dry cell batteries maybe
robot you've never seen him drink water
or tea or eat food I've seen him drink
water yeah did he put the water near his
mouth and then say what's that over
there Oliver and you looked away when
you turn back the glass was empty but
there was a puddle on the floor
robots do that a few minutes you can see
Sir how are you see
like Conan O'Brien right now
I'm being pressed by cloning sir I
didn't do anything
you know this man you're talking to you
right now Ryan you confirm that yeah
you're on your way Ryan all right thank
you sir
give up thank you very much for you the
tight-ass god bless you all
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
kiddie games and hoping the sanest a
friendly comeback Heath Ledger here